the reason why they're such division
right now is because people want people
to go for the jugular and because people
you know are like okay don't talk about
it's either under rug swept or it's just
cut them at the throat like and it's
like the reason why that that division I
feel like exists is because we're not
focused on the real root of the issues
and instead of just talking about
something that is right there that we
can all talk about all joining the
conversation and I'll feel like you're a
part of it like instead of doing that
which is what I feel like your film did
everybody always wants to make some
expose that just murders people and it's
like that's not working like that kind
of mentality isn't working you know but
it's not working right now I know I
think people with that kind of it's
you're not gonna win at this point
everybody keeps trying to do that and
it's not well it's permanent also we
never get a break you know what I
realized this to some extent we as a
country need makeup sex and I think when
you're in a permanent election cycle
yeah
the permanent election cycle really does
set those divisions in concrete you
never get a chance to take off your team
jersey and kind of see people for who
they are and it's why in this moment I
feel like there's something important
happening is that nobody likes to get
called out on their and I'm you know I
always had a terrible problem of being
very defensive about things like that
and I've worked really hard to try to be
less fat but it's a moment where we
might have a chance to see each other
it's going to be a hard conversation and
it's going to take you know a Truth and
Reconciliation is a really difficult
place to be in a society but if we don't
address this truly gaping open wound it
won't ever heal and we can pretend that
we're supposed to have two Americas but
we're really not it's it's okay we're
not all supposed to get along and hold
hands and there will be real divisions
and real challenges and real issues
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe
please don't make me keep going